a friend of mine sent me an article from
the independent called stayin alive and
it was featured Ron Woodruff and it was
about the buyers clubs and the
International gray market which was
developed by people with AIDS to seek
out alternative medications that mainly
dealt with Oh eyes which are called
opportunistic infections and it talked
about Ron Woodruff and now he was
smuggling these drugs from around the
world and setting up this underground
girl guerrilla clinic call the Dallas
buyers club and it was just a
fascinating article I just thought he
was a great character and I wanted to
meet him one night he picked up the
phone and he just said if I said I'm a
writer and I'd like to interview you and
write a film about your life and he said
be here tomorrow you can interview me so
the article was fascinating because I
didn't know this world existed in the
8th I only knew what I was reading in
the news I didn't know about these
underground movement to push access to
different medications and fast tracking
drugs and seeking them out around the
world I'd heard about it through my own
personal experiences with other
illnesses but that's what fascinating me
but when I went and met him he was just
this a character like no I never met and
it was just a really inspiring three
days there's just somebody who would not
die in the sense you know I just the
spirit for life I was surprised to learn
that this was a screenplay that was
written over a decade ago he pitched me
the idea and then I said that I would
write it basically and that was more
than 10 years ago how did you not give
up hope faith that this would eventually
make it to this ringing Robbie Brenner
Melissa called me it was in 2009 because
we set up the screenplay originally at
Universal in 2001 and she said you know
the script came back to Craig and I and
we're gifting it to you you know go with
God and go get
you made and so at that point the first
person that really came to my mind was
Matthew I felt like Matthew had read it
really quickly and he got back to me and
said he loves it he thinks it's
fantastic he wants to do it so then we
needed to find a director and I had
developed another movie with jean-marc
vallée that never got off the ground I
just thought he was so fantastic but
having seen crazy and then something so
different as young Victoria that I
thought he'd be the perfect kind of
person for the movie did you think part
of a lifetime Matthew when you read it I
think part of a lifetime well I'm not
there yet I mean as far as lifetime let
me keep working a little but when I read
it it was obvious that it was high it
was highly original
was very special I said there's
something I remember saying I reminded
myself today I was to come back through
my diary at that time saying boy this I
have some there's something - absolutely
fight for and every single scene and all
the most literal sense it was actually
life and death but this was a a it was
it was very special from the first rate
at what point in the process were you
able to hear the audio recordings that
Craig had made of his conversations with
Ron and also at what point were you able
to meet with the Woodruff family right
well Craig you came over to the house
you and I met did you give me the tapes
at that time it was right around that
time I think yeah John Mark digitized
them for mine so I had all the tapes and
then I Adam transcribed and I was
heading off on a vacation when the
family said took a large locked steel
suitcase that had all these things in
them and was spending my days walk
around with those with me just playing
in my ear and then stop and then go back
and over and over and over anything
would highlight things that I was like
oh that's special and then started to
pull all these different things he would
say about many different subjects
whether it was his police on God whether
it was beliefs on AZT whether it was his
thoughts on women whether his thoughts
about high his mortality his chances of
living or or and then also being able to
pick out when he was just kind of being
full of Shi t oh he just widened himself
up there which was great because he does
it in the in
in the film as well and then I went to
see his family I mean I was I remember
that being a challenging thought for
myself because there's a biography I had
so much with the script that was written
and then so much from the audio tapes
that I felt completely loaded for bear I
mean I felt like I could have worked on
that for months and my imagination was
already flying but there was enough
factual evidence for me to really go to
work on and so I was my remember having
a bit of fear about going to meet his
family because I was like it's what if
it's under what if it underwhelmed where
I am now and that's happened to me
before and that can't happen when you go
meet somebody in real life um but I did
and his family opened up their their
their house to me they had for every
every scrapbook out they had old VHS
documentaries something that nobody knew
he had that they showed me and then they
gave me his diary which was that's and
that was definitely my secret weapon and
as I say that that's when I got Ron's
monologue who's the guy when he's
sitting home alone at night 11 p.m. on a
Saturday not before he got HIV who's
that guy who's that guy on Monday
morning trying to get work not getting
the call to go fix this stereo down the
street as the electrician that he was so
that's what that's when I really felt
like I had I really felt like I had the
ammunition or they at least a life force
but beyond who he was yeah first of all
I was so sold on all of this being a
true story that I looked everywhere for
Eve Saks and I even went to the library
and was looking on microfilm because I
thought maybe she's so old they didn't
have Google maybe she didn't exist in
I'm online and then finally I called
John Mark and he said yeah no she is
she's made up so oh thank you yes
I'll up here people don't worry um but I
just read I've read like a little nerd
and I got every medical journal and
anything written about HIV and AIDS and
just read everything I could get my
hands on and approached it from kind of
where her brain was when she met Ron and
what that meant for her now am I correct
that there was no artificial light on
this shoot it was just kind of
pre-existing light there's no Dolly's
there's no cranes I don't think there's
any orchestral music there's no score
there was no at that great New Orleans
word where we where we shot the film
there's no lot Knoll on yup you know
what somebody knows what lawn yabas
lighting up is etc there were and
basically it was you showed up in the
morning you walked on the set that you
didn't have time to say so what is this
about what are we doing today and what's
it really mean you you know that time
was so precious you you couldn't be so
considerate about anything besides what
was happening in the scene there was one
the one light I remember is John Chaney
the man who friend of mine it was
driving me dropped me off one night at
the trailer and we're we're shooting a
scene and we started to shoot just as we
walked in and he started to back away
and Eve started gonna no no no this is
perfect it's he's perfectly stop the car
because there was a car light shining
through the window and he loved it that
was the one light I remember I took a
little break and came back and
movie-making had totally changed we
didn't meet the lights we didn't need
grips there was one guy with the camera
on his shoulder he was our DP and if we
wanted the shot to change he would put
on shoes with lifts so Rachel what was
behind the decision then for no score um
you know what's interesting you know
Mark is very music driven and he wanted
to approach this from a very specific
place with a lot of sound design that
the that a lot of the emotion would come
again with the natural approach with the
lights I think part of that was matched
by the sound and what you could hear and
and there's real emotion behind it
and he just had a very clear idea of
what he wanted and I think it's very
effective rayon is that is there a point
in real-life basis there is where did
that character come from for you guys
Rann came from I mean he's an
amalgamation of kind of several
different people and then people that
Craig had met at the buyers club and
then we went and spoke to transgendered
people and kind of interviewed them and
then created the character from there
Jared Leto's performance is so
remarkable I wish she was here right now
he's doing his rock star thing in Italy
right now I went back and looked at his
credits from the last ten years the guy
has made only a handful of movies in the
last decade largely because he's been
focusing on music how did you guys even
think of him for this or was it Jean
Marc we thought of him
actually his agent called and he said
you know Jared Leto would be fantastic
and Rachel and I were like oh that's a
good idea so we pitched it to jean-marc
he wasn't very familiar with him and we
said we would set up a Skype call so he
got on the phone with Jared and Jared
was dressed up in character as rayon and
he basically seduced jean-marc for 20
minutes and jean-marc called us after
the the call and he said girls graça we
found rayon he was so sexy oh my god he
he seduced me so that's how Ryan was
born I got that that call with a little
bit different language I got that this
guy is gay he's got a wig on indeed he's
in the lipstick er he tried to pinch me
through the screen he was hitting on me
man I don't know if he means they're not
I did
oh my god that is a great impression of
someone in Toronto we met Jarrod for the
first time but because he you stayed in
character is rayon but as much as that
sounds like an ogre Booga actory thing
it was the most natural thing in the
world in this case it was of course he
came to work with his you know he was he
was round he kept his accent throughout
he kept that voice he his voice is very
low actually but it was it was kind of
incredible I'm only just now comfortable
talking to Jarrod the first few times I
just was like staring at his face
thinking that was rayon that was right
and he just did an expression like ran
like it like it was a different person
but was there a person in Ron's actual
life who was kind of a beacon for him in
this that really did help open his eyes
were there lots of people what did you
learn about him when you read his
Diaries and heard the interviews was it
something he was not one specific person
that I gathered I mean he did gain you
know once he had HIV and he was now
himself considered an outcast he did
gain quite a bit of compassion he didn't
lose who he was that same sob who by any
means necessary to get it done and I'm
looking out for myself that selfish guy
he still remained but he gained a whole
lot of compassion not just for himself
before the for the cause you know and it
was it was important John Mark and I
talked about it a lot about well if you
keep this guy who you who essentially
the same same guy who you meet at the
beginning the humanity will still come
out and we said if we keep the guy
selfish and wanting to make money and
have the Cadillac the Crusader will
reveal itself and we had many times when
we discussed are we going too far and I
remember saying I I think we just have
to trust being who the guy was and that
will reveal itself and and and again
don't have that
that third act will be my wicked ways of
the past who have I become I'm sorry God
it don't have that moment that you can
have it the third act will turn and I
feel like it would feel like it worked
but that was he he was got enlightened
by I think partially just the endurance
of going through and the fight for seven
more years of that I mean he he became
much more alive after he got HIV he
found a purpose
after he got HIV what naturally kind of
lent itself to us of this relationship
of these two outsiders and we just kind
of run we'll just was so much fun to
write but of course that relationship
that we created was we just wanted to
put it in Ron's face and we thought
rayon was the best way to do it and you
know so he couldn't look away so he did
look at this and face his own racism and
his own fears and so that was the
relationship that kind of I've always
been interested in but this sort of
really made it much more clear and more
sound and opened up sort of my version
I'm trying to see how it can apply to
our daily life s'mores
what what what humans can do when you're
faced with with death or someone sit
where there's thirty days or you've got
some kind of some sort of mortal
sickness or you're or I mean I've
applied it to my own life and I've found
that people have talked to maybe it's
not us that had been given the death
sentence but boy the things I've I know
that that I did once my father passed
away for the man of courage and this
sobriety as far as not revering things
or not patronizing things and just
charging forward to the sense of
perspective and what we what we can do I
mean it reminds me that all the time
they say you know we use 10% of our
brain or whatever what do I mean like
Ron were tapping into their eleventh and
twelve percent they were saying we still
got eighty-eight percent to go it's
really inspiring about what the
possibilities are